Beware!
I've come from the future
to warn you that a plague will soon
wipe out all originality on basic cable!
I explain everything on this week's episode
of Angry Nerd!
So the 1995 sci-fi movie
12 Monkeys is mutating
into a series on the Syfy channel.
“A couple of years from now,”
“the entire human race will”
“be wiped out be a plague….”
I asked you what you thought of this,
and the kindest comment was that
it looke like dragged -out version of the
movie,
but with worse actors.
Touche, Ignacio!
This new show worries me,
and not because Terry Gilliam's time-travel
flick is sacrosanct.
Frankly,I think Gilliam's a heretic
for turning the flawless 1962 film La Jetée
into 12 Monkeys in the first place!
12 Monkeys is yet another time slot filled
by a lazy concept.
Flip around the dial tonight--
--ha!
dials...
--and you'll see brand extensions, reboots,
and spinoffs of old public-domain stories.
And 12 Monkeys is just the tip of the derivative-berg!
There are pilots in development
for shows based on movies like
Westworld, Big,
Rush Hour,
Scream,
Marley & Me,
and--
Real Genius!?
Lazlo would be furious.
Okay, okay,
I'll admit that TV adaptations
of the movies Fargo, and
Alien Nation and Buffy worked well,
but these new do-overs are far more likely
to turn out like--
blech!--
Anger Management.
See, we remember the rare successes like MASH,
but we forget the
all-too-common dreck
like the blessedly short-lived series
Ferris Bueller!
“This is television--this is real.”
Wouldn't the money sunk into
licensing these old properties
be better spent on trying to create
y'know, something NEW ?
I'm here to tell you that the
Media Industry Human Centipede
has officially begun eating its own tail.
Hey, come to think of it,
why has no one made a series out of
Human Centipede?
Time to call my agent
and set up a backdoor pilot!
Saturday morning cartoons came to an end last
fall,
but their spirit now seems to be inhabiting
prime time.
I mean, think about it--
there were cartoons based on:
Free Willy, Ghostbusters,
Beetlejuice,
Karate Kid,
Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure,
Back to the Future,
Beethoven,
Mighty Ducks,
The Mask,
Ace Ventura,
Men in Black,
Teen Wolf…
What TV show would YOU like to see turned
into a movie?
Let me know in the comments,
and subscribe to the WIRED channel.
And be sure to watch the--
Ahhhh!
Tiny versions of me!
Stay back, mini-dopplegangers!
Oh wait, those are links
to my other videos.
Watch them all, they're great!
Are they looking at me right now?
I'm afraid to turn my head...